[Music]
okay everybody so
i am so so excited for my next guest on
my show
it is julia raywald aka
kate from fear street part 1 1994 which
is on
out on netflix right now i am so excited
to talk to you
how are you doing today julia i'm good
um i'm a little tired right now because
like i couldn't sleep last night
but i live in uh i live on the east
coast so
the movie dropped at like 3 a.m my time
um so i ended up waking up in the middle
of the night and was like texting the
rest of the cast who's
on the west coast as it was happening
and i was like why am i awake
but i'm excited no and
i'm on the east coast myself and as so
people don't know we're pre-recording
this you're watching this monday it is
monday if you're watching this but
it's actually friday when we're talking
and it's on release day so it's an honor
to talk to you during your
kind of big morning today where your
life's gonna change
now are you see like as we speak
your instagram has about you know 2 000
followers but i know
by monday you're probably gonna have a
billion times that are you mentally
prepared for like the attention you're
about to get
no because for me the 2000 was huge
like my um my siblings and i were having
like a fun
countdown they were like oh you're gonna
hit a thousand followers soon
and i was like wow this is so big and
then like you just said today i woke up
and it was 2000. i was like oh
my god this is crazy yeah so
as we speak while people are in the
future you're probably right now at like
i'm going to predict like 80 000 at
least in a weekend and it'll go up
but um so let's break down this film
because why i'm excited to talk to you
about is we can kind of go
into kate's character and you can
already see with the fan reaction on
twitter
already that you know people are talking
about kate being their fan favorite
that kate deserved better which we'll
get to um
but the big moment i want to talk about
with your character for me which i think
a lot of people ask questions about
is when she kind of leads the charge to
sacrifice sam can you kind of go into
the mindset of kate in that moment and
what she was actually thinking
yeah um i think that um
like at that point it feels like they've
tried
everything that they can do to possibly
like
fight the evil and like get out on top
and
it seems like they've exhausted all
their options this
realistically speaking is the only thing
that they can do left unless they all
want to just
keep dying one by one um
i don't think she's like excited or like
happy about it
and i don't think she's completely
apathetic but i think in that moment
she's like
this is just like what we have to do and
i'll be the one to say it um because i
mean
she she really just wants to get out of
this alive and she wants her friends to
get out too
you know um no one wants to be put
in this dangerous situation for longer
than they have to and i think she's just
kind of
at the end of her rope there yeah no
that that makes complete sense and
you're talking about her friends there
but you're also talking about
uh the character of josh which she
starts having a little thing with
can you kind of explain maybe where you
saw what what was it about josh that
attracted to kate what was drawing kaden
to josh you think
yeah i think it was like like a really
slow kind of unfolding
and i think she i think she knows from
the go that josh has like a little crush
on her
you know i mean she's his older sister's
best friend i think
i think she knows she's got a little
admirer within josh
but then i feel like this is actually
the first day that
um they actually get to spend time with
each other beyond like
saying hi when kate comes over and stuff
you know and she actually gets to see
how cool josh really is and i think
it kind of like opens her up in a little
bit of a way
and she's probably a little more
vulnerable
under the circumstances that she's under
then so i think she's just
a little more willing to be like yeah
this guy this kid's kind of cool
which i know yeah sure it's totally
sweet and i think that people are gonna
love that
pairing but you know as we go on with
this we're having these sweet moments
with kate it's obviously unfortunately
gonna lead to something tragic
but before we even get into that because
i keep teasing it
but what i was so impressed with your
acting is that
i don't think people understand how hard
it is to pull off
doing anything that's very scream queen
and
you absolutely crush it with the
screaming and your reaction to being
afraid
can you kind of give us like i always
wonder how does an actress get to that
place like how do you really feel like
you're
afraid in that moment even though you
know you're on set yeah how do you get
there
um i'd say okay so like the two big
parts where i do the screams i have the
one big scream
in the hallway at the hospital and that
one was like really
scary just like like nerve-wracking to
do
because i was like i think the angle
that it looks
like on screen looks like it could be
scary but when we were filming it
it was just like i saw him coming like i
i was like oh okay this is when i have
to time the scream
and i was like i really hope this like
ends up
looking and sounding right but you can't
really like
practice it so it's just one of those
things where i was like
well take one well i guess uh let's give
it a shot and see how it goes i guess
and then once once i like do it the
first time i was like okay
now i know how this is gonna
feel and then it then it kind of just
became down to timing which was nice
and then so that one was interesting
because there was no
like it was purely just kind of like i
had to like
make it up in a way whereas all of the
screams and stuff
in the grocery store um
those were like i i think because we
were really like tussling with each
other and
we were actually like doing all of the
things it just it
kind of became more of a acting moment
that i could draw from what was actually
happening because it actually was like
really physical and uh building up
so it was kind of nice to it was kind of
fun to do like all the gnarly reactions
yeah and you you do them so well and i
think it's such an under
appreciated skill in the acting world so
it's awesome that you bring it
but going from your gnarly reactions to
gnarly badass moment you have is when
you make this like
makeshift flamethrower now i it happens
really quick but i was wondering like
is that you holding that flame is that
like real pyrotechnics happening or is
like a stunt person like how does that
even happen
yeah it was uh it was a real stunt that
we just um i like for some reason when i
was like
getting ready to like film that day i
was like so busy
focused on um like hand-to-hand combat
that i just like
was like oh yeah there's the part with
the with the flame but um
you know i guess that happens and then
they they like we're like okay like
you're gonna do
the fire stunt now and i was like oh
right but it was just like a can of
hairspray in the lighter
and um they let me practice out back
and i was like it was the biggest flame
that i'd been around but um
i was a little nervous at first and then
when we actually did it i was like okay
that was
i was like let me do it again let me do
it again and they're like no no we got
it
you only need one take you're good i was
like are you sure because i can do it
again
no that's amazing that's like something
that's on this like on my bucket list to
actually make a flame like that and
you're just doing it casually in the
middle
of filming that's pretty cool um so that
leads now which everyone's going to want
to hear about
is the iconic shocking disturbing
death of your character kate through a
bread slicer
um i thought this was the best moment of
the actual film because
and most scenes like that were so
attached to your character that were
like oh they're not going to kill her
and like at that moment like someone's
gonna save her
and it happens and it really is
effective and horrifying which is
awesome
um but is there an honor to that for you
having such an amazing way to go out
like what was your just reaction maybe
reading that in the script the first
time or
even the first time you watched it yeah
um
i was just i was i was super excited
about it i thought it was sick
so i thought i like kind of had to
remind myself that like people were
gonna
be like upset and sad about it because
then like i was watching it with like my
little sister when i watched it for the
first time
and she was like so upset and i was
sitting next to her like
oh this is so awesome and then i looked
over and i was like oh right
all right this is also like this is sad
too
um but yeah i i was excited i thought
the death was really cool and i was like
if kate's gonna die
and if i have to film a death scene i'm
glad that it's like
as awesome as this one was you know
um so it was it was a really cool moment
to
get to see because to see what it looked
like with all like the effects and stuff
because i remember when you were filming
i was like god i wonder what this is
going to like actually look like
because they had me doing it and then
they had like a
prosthetic dummy that they made to like
okay through the thing that like
looked like me and then they added the
effects after so it was kind of cool to
like
actually see it the final product and be
like that is
as gnarly as i was imagining when i read
it in the script
oh hell yeah and how was that like when
you had all the cake on your face do you
take a little bite out of it too while
you're doing that was it like good or is
it just
yeah it was it was like
so we had we did the first dunk and then
from there on out
the rest of the day it was like i had
two makeup people on me the whole day
but neither one was doing
like makeup like one person was
dedicated to touching up the blood
and one person was dedicated to touching
up the cake
and like making sure all like the
frosting was in the right spot
and then like i think halfway through
filming that scene like we took a break
and like had to do our lunch for the day
so i was like outside like covered in
cake just like on my break and i was
like
it was like melting i was like no stay
on stay on
that's amazing so
shifting gears now just from the
excitement around the film you had
posted on your instagram
that it was your first movie premiere in
l.a for fear street part
one and you're on this carpet taking
photos with gillian jacobs sadie sink
what was that like for you oh my gosh
um it was it was absolutely wild
like yeah i think it was just one of
those things where i was like okay i'm
just gonna
like go with the flow and just do
everything as it comes along and it was
like pretty nerve-wracking when i got
there because i was like i
really hate getting my picture taken it
makes me nervous so like the idea of
like
going to the carpet i was like oh my god
um and doing interviews was like nerve
wracking
but then it was like when i got there
like the rest of the cast was also doing
it at the same time
so we were all like seeing each other
while we were going down the carpet and
stuff
and like i was like oh we're all here
we're all having fun
this is awesome and then it was like it
was just fun after that
no yeah it's awesome and it's it's just
exciting talking to you because like
in my head i want to do some reviews i'm
like okay this is my one chance to talk
to her before she blows up
um but here's the thing um i think
people are going to want to know
because you're a newer actress in the
eyes to people about you so
what was the moment in your life that
you knew you wanted to do this and be an
actress like what was that big moment
yeah um let's see i mean i was one of
those kids who grew up doing like
theater as like i was like an actor like
my whole life essentially
but like i i didn't think it was like i
didn't think i was gonna pursue it as a
career when i was a kid
um and then i think in high school
that's when that shift happened
and i'd say the big moment that like my
a my parents were like yeah we can let
her go to college to like
go to art school i guess that's fine and
then also when i like
solidified that i wanted to was like um
our fall place senior junior year of
high school
or no senior year my gosh senior year of
high school we did romeo and juliet
and i played julia and i'm like i'm just
like
a huge shakespeare fan and nerd
and then to actually get to like do that
was
like i was like i really want to
do this for the rest of my life and if
it is a tough road to get there that's
fine like i will do it because this has
to be the thing
and uh haven't looked back since
yeah and it's so impressive like to have
you on this big stage in a netflix film
like this
in a big franchise with arl stein and to
just be
so good in the first time people see you
just so impressive
um but do you have any actresses or
actors you
looked up to or look up to currently
that kind of inspire you
um um let's see
growing up okay i have two i
i've been like a leia salonga fan since
i was like
a child in the womb uh i just she's like
she's my everything i anything she does
is like
inspiring to me and i think i met her
back in college because i waited she did
a show on broadway and i was like i have
to wait i have to get an autograph and
then i met her and i was like oh my god
um and then my other one when i was like
younger
and still today i'm like a huge sarah
michelle geller fan
wow okay comes from i know what you did
last summer
because i was oh it's amazing and
scooby-doo obsessed
um so i love her so those were the two
that i really loved
when i was a growing up and then today
oh gosh there's probably a lot but like
in the past few years like everyone else
um
i really love florence pew i think she's
got the best like screen presence and
just like
star power that i've seen in so long
though that's those are amazing picks
and just with sarah michelle gellar too
like i feel like
it's so cool because it's kind of coming
full circle for you because you're like
going in her
following in her footsteps which is
awesome and as i'm reviewing as i'm
interviewing you i you know
it's almost disturbing me that you have
knives behind you because i'm like oh my
i'm getting flashbacks from the film
there's no bread slicers around you
right no not a bread slicer in sight
thank goodness thank god um so
before i let you go julia is there
you know not spoilers but for the fans
is there
a chance we could see kate in some form
or another in these next two films
um and you don't have to answer that
yeah like i'll be back for the third
movie but
not playing kate exactly okay
okay so we like all are playing
when we go back to 1666 we'll be there
but playing like
1600s people and it's not like the same
character but
all of our characters that we play
they're like kind of very similar and
have like a similar core to them so
there's a lot of cape vibes going on
in my 1600s character and then i think
she might
she makes like a brief like a r.i.p
cameo oh okay great people yeah
yeah cause when i search the hashtag for
fear street you know
people are like just that tweet's going
on and out of kate deserve better so
people are going to see you again they
want more julia
and it's a tribute to your skill as an
actress and your likability but
everybody check out julia's kate now in
fear street part one 1994
on netflix it is out now and part two
and part three will be coming out the
following
fridays julia thank you so much for
joining me and i hope to talk to you
again in the future one day
thank you for having me